what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today
um I have a special guest on the sit
down um his name is Dimitri he is the
founder and owner of LG FG fashion house
um who makes men's and women's luxury
suits and also has a really cool program
where you train men on how to be better
men is that a good way to say it well
yeah because like part of our company's
tenant we're not like a retail and
traditional sense we have sales people
that visit our clients around the world
in about 27 countries so we have
full-time like on the ground offices
like here in London all across Europe
and Canada and Hong Kong in Dubai like
so we're Global uh and our sales people
call on the top one percent of men
primarily men we do have some women as
well and we go to their homes and
offices and we sell them their most
luxurious custom suits and related
apparel
worked with the likes of Jordan Peterson
yes
um you mentioned some really big
celebrities that you are you allowed to
say yeah sure so the ones I can say
Obviously um so like I was on set for
the skyscraper movie which was a big
movie that The Rock was in so we did 12
suits 12 bespoke suits for that movie
that was a really fun project uh the 12
suits for life which is the collection
made for Jordan I I didn't go out and
like promote and say look we made this
but when JP went on the Rogan podcast
started talking about it because people
are asking about that Heaven and Hell
suit which was just so much fun to
create and like just what a great guy
um yeah right now I'm you know
delivering a big collection for your
friend zubi for Kevin Sorbo
um I've been working with him for a long
time that's Hercules for those guys
don't know
um Eddie Hall's got a huge collection
coming right now my president is flying
to LA to deliver a seat to Russell
Peters the comedian Michael franzis he's
getting some stuff from us that's the
Colombo family guy he's amazing
um Frank Mir uh really really excited
this is not even public yet oh Well
Alice Cooper is a big one for us we're
just doing some some very big rock stars
right now so it's pretty cool and it's
really cool because this is a
multi-million dollar brand that you
created from nothing and you came from
you said the Soviet Union yeah yeah okay
can you tell me a little bit about your
background so so I was born in kieving
in the USSR so what's actually really
funny that happened like the way that
the Mind shift has happened in like
Society is everybody always called me
like a Russian guy even though I was
from Ukraine okay and now and now it's
like see I told you I don't why don't
you have an accent why because I was
nine years old when I moved really yeah
I was nine and you still had no I'm
surprised my first language really yeah
Russian's my first your English is
perfect well because it's it's now my
it's my native language now because
that's what I grew up like I finished
high school University everything you
know yeah um I grew up in Vancouver uh
and then so I lived in the Soviet Union
until 92 and then Soviet Union collapsed
and we got on an airplane with a
suitcase and there was a rule when you
left the Soviet Union so they said look
you were nine do you have siblings or no
just me just you me Mom and Dad okay and
the rule was you're allowed one suitcase
per family okay and 50 US dollars to
leave wow because they made it really
like they know so you were nine years
old correct were you like was it scary
for you did you did you know what was
going on no idea so my parents didn't
tell me we were leaving the country
Forever Until the day we left because
what yeah because there was a big risk
of being robbed so what would happen is
like if you're telling people I'm going
to North America and it's like cool and
then they would just like come and Rob
you because you know it's like the
Soviet Union it's what 90s were wild at
that time it was just Mafia and
Corruption and like inflation it was
just like a crazy place to be right wow
so uh my dad I remember uh he's like hey
we're going to stay at Grandma's house
I'm like it's Wednesday but okay and
then we got there it was like Wednesday
night he's like hey tomorrow we leave
from Moscow I'm like where are we going
he's like we're moving to Canada
and I was like I was just like what's
happening Oh Canada to me is like an
imaginary place because back then you
didn't have the like internet you didn't
have you know hundreds of channels on TV
we had three TV channels they're all
Soviet propaganda government channels
right so I don't know anything about the
outside world like the world that I live
in and you know the Soviet Union 92
versus like let's say Canada there was
about a 30-year Gap in development so
everything that this like the the
Canadians and Americans had in 92 right
that was like the Soviet Union was what
North America had in the 60s like the
technology like we had the road you know
the dialy phone with the big ringy thing
we have to call the operator sometimes
to connect us like nobody in the 90s did
that
um so it was just like a very strange
experience obviously because it's at the
time it was like a different planet and
was it traumatizing to you like I mean
I'd imagine you had a whole group of
friends that you just left yeah what was
traumatizing I would say is like
realizing when we arrived in North
America how poor we were that was
actually quite traumatizing because so
you didn't know well in the Soviet Union
everybody's just poor like it's just
normal for your grandma you know to wake
up at five in the morning to go in the
breadline because she has to you can't
get bread if you're there at eight in
the morning there'll be no more bread so
you know the grandmothers the retirees
would get up super super early go to the
store and then wait in line for two
hours to get a loaf of bread because
they would sell out because there was
always a food shortage it was always the
case in the Soviet Union but you had no
idea no so I remember like you know I'm
on the airplane and I remember that very
very clearly because we're flying from
Moscow to Montreal then we changed
planes and and on the airplane to give
me like this little Etch A Sketch toy
I've never seen that before I'm like
this is a crazy technology like oh you
can draw on it and then like pull it and
the thing disappears and draw again I
saw my first can of Pepsi I've never
seen a can of soda before in 92 like I
never I just did an exist in the Soviet
Union and then the other thing I
remember when we landed in Vancouver I
needed to go pee and there was a urinal
in the urinals I had no I'm like what
I've never seen a urinal like I
just remember thinking like what is
happening what is this stuff
so would you say
a question it might be but were people
happier in the Soviet Union versus
Canada because it's interesting because
it like I asked this question to someone
like an Uber driver the other day that
was from like a third world country and
he he said that people were happier
there I would say but I would imagine it
was so corrupt maybe not I would say it
was a really so this is something I was
actually thinking about this morning
because I woke up literally thinking
that question so I started researching
it this morning I just needed to know
for myself because I was thinking back
to that right like I will introspect and
I'll say this
people in North America
are happier
now let me rephrase that people back
there were happier people back there
were happier but they were less unhappy
than the people in North America
so the reason why I'm trying to say is a
very difficult thing to kind of
comprehend is like people in North
America have a delusional degree of
unhappiness
like the unhappiness you know because
you have like a pretty
comfortable life and then you're
creating problems that don't exist
you know what I mean so so yeah people
in North America are probably both
happier and unhappier at the same time
like there's just like this we have
unhappiness within what should be
perceived as happiness what I say people
in the Soviet Union were happier
you have to ask my parents to probably
go back into the 90s were pretty nuts
what do you think they would say
my dad 100 would say they were happier
back there really 100 yeah wow that's
crazy yeah so what happened when you got
to Canada
well I remember like we went to a
supermarket it was full of food I just I
hadn't seen cereal before so I was like
whoa cereal and cartoons like we got
like a cartoon every week you know
delivered on Soviet propaganda TV and it
was like some same cartoon my parents
grew up on because in the Soviet Union
you know when you kill capitalism when
you kill Innovation nothing's new
so everything's just recycled over and
over so it's like we're literally
watching the same cartoon our parents
watched
so it was like
a planet yeah yeah and so then what was
school like uh it was tough like I said
I realized very quickly that we were
poor that was a difficult thing because
again back in the Soviet USSR everyone
everyone's just so so it's kind of yeah
just like you felt different from
everyone else because well I got made
fun of because I dress different right
like I just I had patches in my pants
like my great grandmother who lived into
like the early 2000s uh would like
repair if I like me it had a hole in my
classy you know Soviet sweatpants which
is a slobs that's what we wear you know
I had the track suits yeah and mine had
patches on the knees because my gray
grandma would stitch them up like
everybody in the Soviet Union learned
different skills because nothing would
get done that you needed done like if
you wanted something fixed you just had
to do it is it hard when you come on
shows like mine and these girls talk
about their trauma and you're like you
know what I mean it's just you actually
came from the Soviet Union and they're
talking about how hard it was for them
you know I mean look I think I I'm
privileged in the sense that my parents
like raised me in one home and they
stayed together and obviously there's
disadvantages some of those girls had
because like they're raised by a single
mom right that has like profoundly
negative consequences on them like
through their adolescence as we see now
like actualize their statistics and data
um but I mean are there problems pretty
stupid yeah they're pretty stupid but
you can't tell them that yeah so we went
to Canada and then where'd you go to
school uh so I went uh to high school
and Elementary School in Vancouver and
then UBC University British Columbia and
Vancouver for University okay and what
was that like
um UBC was a really interesting
experience so again this is kind of
getting into what Canada looked like and
maybe still looks like uh my dad tells
the story I don't remember it as well
but he said he took me to the career
like not career that he took me to like
initiation at UBC like to check out the
campus and stuff and you know we're
driving my dad's 89 Camry and we pull
into the parking lot and Vancouver was
an interesting town in the early 2000s
because in 2000 uh Hong Kong seceded
from the British Empire and it went back
into Chinese Rule and so all the wealthy
people in Hong Kong it's one of the
wealthiest cities in the world they
moved their families to Vancouver
because there was more sort of certainty
in a democratic country so you know I'm
like a whitish looking guy obviously and
like at that time the university is
probably 90 Asian I mean that's just oh
that's just the demographic of Vancouver
like Vancouver is just that way I did
not know that yeah Vancouver is really
profound I don't know the total area but
I know that like at the University
there's many times on group projects
where like I have the best English and
I'm the one that wasn't born in the
country that's pretty normal in Mexico
it's a normal Vancouver experience I had
no idea yes like I grew up on like
Chinese food I had a Chinese girlfriend
like that's just my friends were Chinese
it's just like that's fine like that's
just what it was okay but there so much
money and so you know you get into UBC
and it's a very wealthy School very
wealthy area for you know this
demographic and the parking lot's got
like Lamborghini like straight up
Lamborghinis and like Bentleys on it and
my dad uh tells me the story and I don't
remember it but he told me that he's
like when we went to the initiation day
when we're in the parking lot you my dad
said you looked at me and you said I'm
going to drive a car like that one day
but I'm gonna buy it for myself it won't
be you
wow because obviously the kids there
were getting the stuff and by the way
that's a very typical Vancouver
experience you'll see a lot of 19 20
year old kids driving landfill so it's
just how it is
so um tell me you mentioned you had a
sales job yeah in in college yeah was
that your first job yeah I worked at a
gas station for three weeks and got
fired because I had all sorts of ideas I
think and whenever you're a creative
type of person I didn't know what that
meant it happened to me right sort of
they hated me in corporate because I was
always trying to put bring in like new
technology and stuff yeah that was me
yeah okay well I learned this later like
because people started referring to me
as being creative I didn't think I was
creative I didn't know what that meant
right
um
and so and so I got into the you know
the the whatever University and then I
was working a gas station for three
weeks I get fired because I just I'm
annoying my manager okay fine
um then I'm rollerblading to class
somebody approaches me like hey you look
like you're working you know your your
old brain to class you know you really
care about your Fitness and motivation
what I didn't say is like no I can't
afford the 75 cents a day parking and
I'm parking on the highway taking a bus
from because we had a free bus pass and
I lived about an hour and a half from
campus so I would drive uh to like where
I can park on the highway get on the bus
and then take the bus and then get off
the bus and rollerblade to the campus
Because the bus didn't go like totally
to campus I'm so it's like that's oh
you're rollerbladed by the highway oh
yeah yeah but I'm like I'm saving 75
cents I'm like I either look more I
don't know what I look like but I was
just poor I wasn't motivated I
rollerbladed in college too that's funny
not just for fun no I just I was and I
just imagine just imagining like this
really busy highway it's just the skin
rolling yeah I was just you know with my
bag and like I just I needed go to
school you know I wasn't thinking about
like whatever I mean obviously I
probably looked like a total loser
because that's what it was but
somebody's like hey you know I don't
think you looked like a loser oh no no
no no no no no it's like okay
there's something that people respect
about people that are just like crazy a
small percentage of people were
respected okay it's like when I um I was
telling the story yesterday on the show
how I was going door to door in
neighborhoods like asking for a job and
it was just more of a social experiment
but people respect it to be wealthy
people wealthy people yeah like people
that just don't care if they look stupid
they're trying to get it done listen I
buy from any salesperson that knocks on
my door and they're good I'll buy I
don't care what they're selling I'll buy
it because I respect the hustle and if
they look like they hate their job I
won't buy you know my family does that
but with kids lemonade stands I'll
always stop for a lemonade stand I'm
like get that money sure and I always
pay like I always give them like 20
bucks even though it's 50 cents I had a
funny story on Sunday A door-to-door
salesperson came to our house in Estonia
and my wife bought whatever this person
was selling and then the person asked
it's like can you tell me about you know
she's trying to get like approach on
other families to like to like you know
have a little bit of a preparation
before she knocks on their door she's
like and who lives in this scene or that
unit I'm always like what do you mean
she's like you know this quartile this
my wife's like this is one house
like the salesperson thought that our
house was a quad which I'm like and I'm
like baby we made it you know that's
that's like a really nice
like yeah it's one house yeah this guy's
been to my house so
um
yeah so so somebody identified me as
being ambitious uh which okay I guess I
was more like just whatever but yeah I
got recruited to selling encyclopedias
door-to-door yeah and so yeah that was
crazy that was a tough sell that was it
was crazy and I remember
um you know knocking on doors that we
went to Ontario Ottawa and Toronto
because what happened was we relocated
for the entire summer like we literally
got in a caravan last day of finals and
we drove like 4 000 miles away from home
and we were just because that way we
can't quit it was like true Vega bond
from a van you know you live in a
basement with like six other dudes
you're working six days a week 14 15
hours a day just knocking on doors that
was the thing right and I'm like well I
got nothing better to go back to so why
not
um and you know it's like it's like
super hot I don't know about Fahrenheit
it's like 35 degrees Celsius 80 60
humidity you got nosebleeds just from
the humidity outside because they're
Smog and you're sometimes it rains and
you're knocking on doors like hi I want
to sell you some some encyclopedias
um but thankfully you know
um the lessons that that we gained from
that like perseverance positive
affirmation just making the best out of
a shitty situation and actually now that
I think back even just voluntarily
putting yourself through hardship
because that's a safe environment to
fail and it's not like a war that if you
fail you blow up it's like if you fail
you get rejected you might cry a little
bit but you're gonna have to pick
yourself back up and keep going and I
love that right especially for a man
again I can see to my own experience
like that right of passage experience
that and we don't have in North America
because there's no you know and there's
no
um there's no Army conscription you just
as a guy there's no rite of passage I
Believe In The Rite of Passage because I
went through that in that and thankfully
I discovered that um I'm okay at sales
and I have a certain passion for
influencing people
um and I like the thing that you know
that summer I came back I had eight
thousand dollar check it was not huge it
was eight thousand dollars but I was
able to pay off my tuition because it
was six thousand only tuition at the
time you know so kind of dating myself
here the next summer I went back I took
home a forty nine thousand dollar check
I saw an encyclopedias yeah so I bought
it so I bought myself how much did the
encyclopedia please go for about 600
bucks it wasn't that expensive but you
just you know you you learn yeah and
then so so like I was like
8K that was like 50 49 like 50 then like
50 then I jumped like 130k in one summer
Jesus so 23 this is how much my life
changed I was rollerblading to class at
20 at 23 I was 23 I was a full-time
University student I was paying my own
tuition tuition and I was a homeowner
wow so that was a really quick
turnaround right and so you went from
literally rollerblading to class yes
some guy I'm assuming he mentioned it
was a lady yeah the lady saw you um
thought you were ambitious yeah
recruited you was it her company no so
it was it's a huge company out of
Nashville Tennessee and they're like a
big direct selling company okay and so
this company's been around for like 160
170 years like they've been around
forever and he goes it was started by a
pastor selling Bible Store to Door like
that was the kind of origin story
um yeah and you know what's crazy is
obviously my friends all thought I was
signing up for like to be human
trafficked somewhere
right because they're like what and my
mom thought I was not she's like wait
you're gonna go four thousand miles away
from home and knock on door selling
books and and this is 2003 2004 my first
summer 2003 it's like we have Internet
and I'm like but Mom I think this will
be good for me you know I like I was
just feeling this drive first so
essentially after college no this is in
college this was the summer this is the
summer yeah all three so every summer we
would go for three months and and you
know sell and then of course you know my
fourth I did five years at University
because of the two degrees by my fourth
and fifth year I would usually miss the
first couple weeks of school because I
had sold so much that I have to stay and
like deliver everything so when did you
start your company 2010
okay so was that I'm just trying to
figure out the timeline yeah so O3 so oh
one I go to university okay O3 is my
first Summer Okay and then I sell an
03040506 and then I do my graduating
year I sell an 07 and then I do one more
year because in 07 I sold that summer I
made like 130 000 uh that summer so I
saved up like quite a lot of money for a
university student coming out of school
and then I travel for a year and then in
2008 I go I sell books again and then uh
I travel again for a year and a half and
then I come back and start a company so
I got a lot of traveling done like
before I kind of took on this this you
know undertaken and what inspired you to
start your company
um what like what was that was there an
aha moment yes like what okay one thing
I didn't mention is in 2008
I left the book thing before I went to
travel I took a corporate consulting job
in Texas
lived in Dallas and uh that lasted three
months
I gotta go because same thing I was just
super ambitious and like like just
having all these ideas
I I relate to that so much yeah they
hated me in corporate they hated me well
the corporate people are not like you
know anybody with an MBA just hates me
because I I don't think like them at all
like I'm not linear I want to explore I
want to take risks you know I read a
statistic today that an average
millionaire files bankruptcy 3.5 times
in their life that's insane really yeah
that's insane I I was shocked when I
read that but I looked at the data like
oh my God there's tasks to back that up
which means that millionaires are people
that will take risks and fail and try
again until they succeed so that's a
resiliency argument actually it's not a
failure argument it's a resiliency
argument right and so
um corporate people they're not into
failure like they just want the safest
thing for everything and I'm going in
there let's try this let's try that and
they're like
you're insane and so three months in I'm
like I can't do this so I left
and I was just thinking like I I
probably should start a business because
um I don't think I'm employable like I
just realized I don't think I'm
employable
at first I had that same thought like
literally when I was in corporate
because I would always go to my
management and just ask them like can we
use this software like why are we doing
it this way this doesn't make any sense
and like I'm 24 22. I don't know 22 to
24 I think I was so like what is this
chick talking about she doesn't know
anything yeah plus I hate stupid rules
thank you for no reason stupid rules
yeah yeah yeah stupid rules it's okay so
they let you go why why suits so I made
a list of things uh again I wanted to be
strategic uh there was an incident in my
life that I refer a lot to new people we
hire in our company which is I had a
mentor I talked about at the show
yesterday he had sold this company for
about 50 million dollars at 39 years old
and then he started at a non-profit he
put me on the board of the non-profit
just so I can learn he said I just want
you to learn it was a wonderful thing he
did so it was a Sunday I'm in his office
on a Sunday and we're raising money to
build a new facility at UBC to build a
new building at UBC that was the
fundraiser he undertook for his
organization
non-profit and uh this guy walks in this
little chubby uh white curly hair with a
hat guy looks about 60. walks in he's
you know shakes hands and gives him an
envelope while Sia and walks away
and so
this matter of mine
um
ayal he opens the envelope and there's a
half a check for half a million dollars
from him to you from no not from him to
you from this from to me to from this
old man to you all that was a donation
he gave half a million dollars to help
fund this building that he always
building wow half a million dollars okay
so I'm I don't know I mean I had money
at the time but not like half a million
dollars to donate money you know because
I'm like 24 and I'm looking at like uh
what I've never seen a half a million
dollar check before it's incredible
experience actually to be in that energy
you know and I go that guy just gave you
half a million dollars he's like yeah he
donates half a million dollars to US
every year
I go you see the biggest donor he's like
no there are people who do a million
dollars a year for us keep in mind we're
building a you know transparently like
uh growing up Jewish in the Soviet Union
this this was building a a a campus uh
you know building for the uh Halal
foundation so like the Jewish student
Community which I'm sure is going to get
a lot of hate online because all these
conspiracies no there's no conspiracy I
grew a poor
um but that Community does have a ton of
money like it's a very you know wealthy
community and these are and these are
very successful people but this is the
most unassuming little old man that
walked in gave a check for half a
million dollars you know
and I go hey y'all like
what do you have to do with your life
to be able to give away a half a million
dollars for just something you believe
in
and they all like thought about he goes
you know
all of these guys do something different
like Neil was the guy's name that gave
the money happens to be in construction
his friend Jonathan's an accountant he
gives like a million dollars
he went through all these names he's
like they all do different the one guy's
an orthopedic surgeon everybody does
something different goes but there's one
thing they all have in common and this
is profound to hear this at 24 he goes
the one thing the Olive in common is
they've all ever only done one thing
what does that mean he goes they've all
been married to the same woman since
I've known them for the last 30 plus
years and they've all only had one job
mind blown you know that was that was
prophetic because
like you know you go now to 2023 and
people jump from relationship to
relationship jump from job to job it's
too hard and doesn't work doesn't work
like this they don't people don't
understand or value commitment and value
resiliency people value oh I'll get a
200 raise if I switch jobs it's like
okay well good luck living life with
that logical fallacy as much as you
might believe it to be true but here's a
guy that sold this company for like 50
million dollars getting a half a million
dollar donation right in front of me
telling me do one thing so my thing was
like if I start a business I want to
only do one thing so I have to figure
out what that thing is does that make
sense
so
um I'm talking to my best friend my best
friend skipped two grades of high school
between his parents they have three phds
so in like biochemistry like crazy
intelligent family sister is a doctor
like like my friend is a brilliant guy
and he got a Goldman Sachs internship in
New York as like a second year
university student he's a brilliant guy
I'm not like him
my other best friend I have four best
men at my wedding one has an honors
Physics degree one is the guy I just
told you about one guy now works works
at the World Bank graduated University
with a masters in three years speaks
fluent Chinese
he's from he's a white dude learn
Chinese won a competition got sent to
China for an internship got his master's
degree now works of the World Bank so I
have some pretty smart friends and I'm
really intimidated by them like my
friends I just got lucky are like really
really smart people
and so I'm talking to my best friend I'm
like man I feel I feel very unsecure
because I want to build something I want
to do something
but you're like
skipping two grades of high school how
do I compete with a guy like you because
you know when you're winning you have to
be uncomfortable you have to be winning
against somebody there's a competition
right
and peleg
I'm sure he's listening to this later
he's like
he told me something he's like you know
he's he was a buy side analyst that was
his internship that he was doing
somewhere and he was like meaning that
he would evaluate companies based on how
much they're really worth and so he
would go with these very like you know
um very qualified management teams and
investment teams to go interview you
know like leaders of companies and he
goes there's two kinds of Rich guys that
I've met that's what he told me he goes
the first kind is the one that goes to
an Ivy League school gets into an
investment Bank you know Goldman Sachs
JP Morgan whatever and that guy goes
becomes a managing director but then
you're competing against all the other
guys that went to Ivy League schools he
goes but the most successful people I've
met evaluating companies is somebody who
is dominating a non-sophisticated
industry but what do you mean he's like
well the richest guy I've interviewed
recently owned the waste removal company
he collects garbage but his competitors
are not Harvard guys they're
unsophisticated so he's like if you go
into an unsophisticated industry and
learn to dominate it you can do really
really well
and so I'm thinking like okay what's a
non-sophisticated industry that has
nothing to do with garbage because I
don't want to pick up garbage
and I see suits I'm thinking okay well
that seems pretty simple who's my
competition that suits
like some guy in a store you know sure
the store might have a nice brand but
it's just like some guy like hello sir I
work in retail I can beat that guy in
sales so it's unsophisticated so that
was my number one thing it had to be
unsophisticated and easy to learn the
reason I had to be easy to learn is I
coming out of the encyclopedia business
I had a lot of friends that I'd
recruited into that business that were
selling books with me so I can recruit
them into suits I also wanted a product
that required no further schooling
because I spent five years in school I
knew that Academia was not for me and I
also wanted a product that gave me uh
because I had delusional aspirations of
being International I don't want to sell
insurance or financial services or real
estate because then I have to be married
to my city I want to be able to travel
the world and build around the world
which actually has come true
so that was my decision it was like
unsophisticated how many cities are you
in oh over 30 something oh wow yeah yeah
so that was a decision
um but
here's something funny so my last name
is tukshar I didn't know this until a
couple of years ago as my dad was
researching some of our family history
and Yiddish which is like the language
that Jews in the Soviet Empire spoke
means Taylor
like a means clot and share like sheer
or in French that means to cut so my
last name actually means Taylor I had no
idea turns out my great-grandfather had
been like a really really prominent
tailor
pre-World War II Soviet Union and so
maybe there was a little bit of divine
intervention that happened on the back
end that was unintentional but the
things that led to this were just
logical strategic decisions so
who was your first soup for
uh my first suit was Howard uh he was a
partner at a law firm called gowlings
okay which is what the time was the
largest law firm in Canada I don't know
about now they're gallowing something
now they're they've merged with some
Japanese company and I made a cold call
on the phone
he was if I remember correctly he was a
lawyer that was Aboriginal law in Canada
it's a big thing a lot
I pick up the phone I cold call him
and I'm like hi I'm Dimitri I'm selling
suits blah blah and I sound really good
on the phone like at this point I've
been door-to-door so like I I'm not
saying it I said on the phone I sound
pretty competent even though I'm 25
years old 20s 25 just turned 26 I'm like
I'm pretty competent
and Howard is like you know and he talks
like rich men talk we'll uh you know
slow and deep
and thoughtful
so um how much do your suits cost
that's what he asked me now I know that
I've done sales I'm not going to answer
that question I have to because I know
it's a trap and I don't know which way
it's going and I said what do you like
to spend on your suits
now we expect them to say as little as
possible when he goes I would never buy
from a company that sells a suit for
less than three thousand dollars because
that company doesn't know what they're
doing
and I said I'll bring you all the I'll
bring you the nice stuff then that's
what I said I have a video about this so
I show up at his office 27th floor
overlooking uh overlooking uh airport
there's a airport
on the west coast it's like uh like the
seaplanes will land on it like a harbor
you know uh Vancouver I mean that's just
how it is
so I come in and the first thing Howard
says he's like damn you're young
he just looks and you're young I was I
and I this is before facial hair I'm
like 24 25 you know I can't grow a beard
yet
and I and I'm like okay he's trying to
take power over me I understand what's
happening here and I go Howard let me
ask you a question would you rather buy
a suit from an old incompetent tailor or
a young hungry guy like me
because I'm challenging now I'm like
because I'm I know he sees me in him you
know what I'm saying or he sees himself
in me like he's like oh this guy's
hungry and he's like
okay let's sit down so we sit down and
he buys a suit he buys a suit how much
is the suit it was it was like 35 3600
kind of like what he said he would spend
right and of course at the time I'm
thinking that's a lot of money but like
I'm just playing it cool
sign him up and then he's like let me
show you something he's just he sees
that I'm really like I'm like at this
point I am ambitious now I'm like I can
say this is now ambition right like he
shows me how to win he's like you see
that little plane over there that's mine
so he lived on Vancouver Island which is
like Victoria like the naimo like Comox
there's all these little towns on the
island about two hour Ferry but it's
about a 45 minute flight in so he flew
his own seaplane from the island to work
every morning
and I'm standing there and I never seen
anything like that I'm like I want to
work with people like that for the rest
of my life because that's freaking cool
that's freaking cool that was my first
suit so
and what have you learned from like
working like what are one like top one
percent men like the number one women we
talk about that all the time these men
um so yeah what are they like here's
what I teach to all of our Young Guns
it's a really there's one word that
describes the one percent if you're
paying attention the word is predictable
okay they're extremely predictable I can
tell you exactly where each of my
clients will be at every hour on the day
on any day of the week for the next 10
years they're predictable like if I call
that guy at 3 P.M on a Thursday I know
he's in the office if I call him at 8pm
on a Friday I know he's at a son's
baseball or soccer game and that goes
for the next 10 years like there's you
know like especially because your
content is like men and women and Inter
you know inter sort of gender relations
kind of thing and it's like oh the guy
doesn't text me back and this and that
it's like you know you have the dark
Triad and women become attracted to sort
of like
um emotional roller coaster right
um yes successful but that's not
successful no it's not successful so
women are looking for men that are
unpredictable and that have dark Triad
traits yes but the top one percent of
men don't typically well think about it
man like woman think about this look
it's like it's like imagine that you're
actually really really successful that
means other people rely on you right
like that means that you are a doctor or
a surgeon which means like what happens
if you skip the surgery or your schedule
you're like you're never going to be a
doctor again it means you're a lawyer
representing your client in a case that
could alter his life forever and you
miss your your schedule you don't show
up to court because then nobody under
your text and you don't reply is that a
formula for Success will people trust
you and especially if you're like I'm
trying to
because I grew up in the small business
world so it's a little different than
like
like they talk about high value men and
men of value and I would say have you
heard do you know the difference tell me
high value men are typically in more
like corporate settings they're in more
um like they they tend to go to like
nice events like they're from what I
understand where the men of value are
the kind that go get a piece of land and
like don't talk to anybody like does
that make sense well so statistically
that makes sense do you know what
percentage of Corp so here's the stat 50
of them this is an actual status 50 of
all millionaires are small business
owners
wow 50 of all millionaires so about one
one in nine Americans are millionaires
now in terms of like working age men
about one in nine are Millers that's not
a little it's one in nine it's more than
I thought actually yeah it's it's like
one in nine one to ten depending on who
you ask you who I've seen one the nine
I've seen one and eleven but let's say
about ten percent whatever half of them
half of them are uh half of them are
small business owners you know what
percentage of them are corporate
less than 10 percent of milliliters come
from corporate it's actually a very
small percentage of people that become
corporate millionaires it's mostly half
of it as small business owners wow
there's a lot of doctors in there
obviously you know some Pilots you know
people in sort of like these Niche
professions where they're the best at
what they do
when I think of millionaires I think of
like three categories where it's like
there's like one two for like five like
under 10 millionaires like 10 million or
less which is like one cat yes that is a
different category yeah and then ten
plus yep yeah and and then 50 plus is
like yeah that's the Ultron yeah that's
like when then because a hundred million
plus is like private jets
anything over 50 million our life's the
same there's nothing you can buy that
you can buy the Jeff Bezos it's like
it's the same thing yeah yeah so tell me
like where do your clients typically
fall in out of because I'm thinking
there's 10 million we're gonna go 10
millionaire or less
We Believe based on the clients like our
own research and our clients yeah that
our average client average client
probably makes about half a million a
year okay the average millionaire only
makes about a hundred thousand a year
FYI wow yeah people think oh millionaire
makes 20 million a year no a Millionaire
on average makes about a hundred
thousand they're just strategic and
smart now obviously those are the guys
with three million dollars those aren't
the guys with you know 50 million so
what are can you tell me the differences
between those three categories well at
all what specific differences like I'm
just thinking like what types of jobs do
the guys in the 10 million category have
versus the 10 to 50 and the 50 plus oh
anything over 10 is business owner okay
well no that's not true that's not true
there's always there's always a couple
of like Partners at law firms or
investment banks that are like the one
out of ten thousand guy that's just like
the best that is in the screen he's just
crushing it right but primarily it's
business owners the 10 to 50. yeah yeah
anything or anything over 10 you need to
be uh owning a business or being in a
company or an organization that you
effectively own your business so
Financial Services has the reputation
for creating the most millionaires and
what are financial services so let's say
you're working in a high level
Investment Bank or you're just a private
investment advisor which I'm sure your
parents have and that private investment
advisor just works with Rich families he
might be working for a big bank but he's
actually working for himself because
he's building his own client portfolio
which is what we do in our company like
our sales people represent lgbg but
they're effectively building their own
business within our organization because
you know we help them with the branding
we help them with the leads we help them
with
um well warm leads etc etc but
ultimately they build that client
portfolio and then sell to those clients
repeatedly to generate money and they
run it like their own business do you
ever get nervous that they'll like take
your bit like just leave and like listen
if they if they want to compete
absolutely great why not and I'll tell
you something like this is not a Dimitri
thing or an industry thing or a company
thing this is a life thing like like you
wanna you have two options right like
this is a leadership thing this might be
a little bit outside of typical content
but you have two options on how you grow
people right either you limit people
from reaching their potential because
you're scared of what they're capable of
and then you're stuck with employees
whose potential you've limited yeah I
feel the same way I feel like if people
want to go let them go it's like you
can't listen if I can find if I'm
hypergamy for females is very similar to
hypergamy for business you know so I did
a little bit statistical research
because you contradicted me yesterday
and you were right you told me that
wealthy men cheat more and I said I
don't think so and you were right
wealthy men do cheat more about 33 of
wealthy men over 350 000 a year income
she'd compare to about 20 percent of men
in general but just for women it's
reversed
poor women cheat way more than wealthy
women
women interesting but what what but what
does cheat mean so it means like let's
like let's they say yeah yeah cheat
means that first of all they're already
in a committed relationship we're
talking about married couples so poor
married women we're rich women probably
are in less relationships I would guess
less relationships yeah I would imagine
like rich women aren't as married as
poor women well rich women are actually
well so we're talking just married
people we're talking just just out of
married people I don't know I didn't
think about it that hard
so like just out of married people
there's women who are married and are
wealthy and there's women who are
married and are poor okay if a woman is
married wealthy or if a woman's married
poor overwhelmingly that's a reflection
of her husband overwhelmingly right
because we know that like most of the
money at the highest levels is made by
men this is just statistics I'm not
judging I'm saying this is just
statistics
so so so why is it that like so why is
it like poor women cheat more well why
do women cheat
like so men that are rich are cheating
more apparently and they look in the
stats here because they just have way
more options yeah and by the way it's
not necessarily the men going out there
and like I'm gonna cheat because I'm
rich no they're just attracting way more
female attention and those women that
are cheating with those men they're
complicit in that like the woman wants
that guy knowing what he's at yeah well
I think a lot of guys would have a hard
time in Tiger Woods position where he
comes every day statistically most
faithful man on the planet actually what
you'll think about it Tiger Woods listen
listen okay listen so Norm Macdonald who
died last year and I love normal the
comedian get this joke you know like
Tiger Woods uh comes home after a golf
tournament not come home come to a hotel
and he's like hello I'd like a chicken
sandwich please what no I don't want a
to end all I just want
a chicken sandwich because I've spent
time with professional athletes I'm
gonna tell you guys a story so I had a a
friend who's a professional athlete
who's a neighbor of mine
and I'm like I'm not gonna name names
but very famous person like very very
high level athlete everybody knew he was
making a ton of money so I've spent
a lot of time pro athletes
we go to one of his games
won't say the sport we go one of those
games
we're sitting uh in the family section
because I know there's guys he's like
here's some fat you can go into the
family sections me and my wife in the
family section and the family section is
like right at where the action is we're
like literally we could probably high
five if we reach over enough right right
two girls are in the front row I know
who they are but they look good
and they're yelling at him now imagine
this hey hey
well together you and us
and he's just like he hears it right so
imagine you're a man okay you go to work
you go to work I don't care what you do
you're an account you show up at the
office yeah and two of the hottest 22
year olds you've ever seen show up at
your office where you work hey we want
to double team you today what do you
think what would you do as a man it's
like that's just the life that he lives
I've seen this I've seen this well
that's and that's my opinion on it it's
just like like I feel like as women it's
just like I think a lot of guys would
have a hard time in his position imagine
typing but this guy's not a tiger man
even even even a good a good man who
doesn't want a tea if you every day you
know it's like at some point he might
but this doesn't even like hey we worked
together and we had a long conversation
we connected this isn't that these are
these are women showing up at his work
right dressed provocatively and there
and by the way these are not sixes and
sevens these are some of the hottest
women you'll ever see because they know
that that's how they validate themselves
because that's the guy they want and
they show up at your work and they're
just soliciting you for that like
they're just like hey anything you want
right here and that's every day of his
life and he's traveling 80 of the time
he's married with kids wow and they know
it because he's in the community right
right and I don't know if this guy ever
took it up like I've never seen him take
it up because but it's just part of his
everyday routine where like you can't
even like walk to work without some
check rack I've I've had another one I
golf with the captain of my of my hockey
team uh NHL team one time we golf
together like I knew him from you know
just being a client he's like come golf
with me sure just me and him so I spend
you know I I'm terrible at all but 18
holes with the captain of the team I'll
say yes every time a girl recognizes him
she ran over for a selfie and an
autograph she's like oh you can save my
Instagram you know like women at that
level when they see a guy like that it
was crazy for me because I've never been
treated by women like that just just
transparently I didn't know that was a
thing right the way that women treat
those guys like it's like the way that
guys treat the most beautiful woman they
ever see like they're getting DMS these
guys they're getting approached on the
street like it's just crazy well I think
that's where like a lot of times the red
pill and like the trade cons kind of get
into arguments because it's like the red
the tradcon guys will be like well you
should never cheat on your wife and it's
like some of the red pill guys are like
well you've never been in that position
you know and so it's like they'll be
like shaming the the guys that cheat for
like being in a position they've never
been in I've talked I've talked to my
wife about this you know and I'm really
open with my wife like we have we have
you know we've been married 10 years
right and we've been together for 13
years so we have four kids and I'm like
I'd say like I don't know what how I
would react to that it's like I would
like to believe the best of myself like
I would like to believe that I would
hold myself the highest standard and
certainly like I realize there's always
opportunities but like I've never had
like two cheerleaders dressed like
scandily and beautifully like walk up to
me and be like hey what are you doing
right now let's go back to our hotel I'd
just be like uh like I don't know what
my brain would do like I would like to
believe the highest of myself I really
would and I'd like to say hey I'm gonna
I'm gonna make the right decision but
I'm not tempted at that level do you
know what I mean like when things are
transpiring and escalating I can catch
on pretty quickly like oh she's giving
me the eye this isn't that this is
different
yeah and I think I think that's where
like sometimes like they they'll get
into like disagreements I don't know and
the one thing that's interesting you
said on the show how you were talking
about how you should sleep around as a
guy when you're single when you're
single yes you should yeah and I because
I think a lot of times the Chad counts
will come in and be like yo you
shouldn't contribute to the problem you
you kind of seem like a mix a bit uh
well I'm just I'm a realist yeah and
that's like and that's what the red pill
guys are saying it's like well we're
just responding to the women like we
wanted we wanted a girl at a 20 year old
virgin but they don't they don't really
exist I don't I don't believe that's
necessarily true I think that what you
said yesterday struck me as you said you
have to be a little bit more selfish I
agree with that that's the Ein Rand you
know the randian philosophy which is
like if you act in your own
self-interest it's up to everybody else
to act in their own self-interest and at
least the best outcome well I'm a pretty
hardcore capitalist in that sense I do
believe you should act in your
self-interest and I believe others
should too as a man when I'm 23 24 and
I'm single it is in my interest to to
sleep with as many beautiful women as I
possibly can that is 100 of my interest
and it's 100 in the women's interest to
get a commitment from the best guy they
can possibly get and that's exactly I
should be trying to do yeah and if I'm
unable and here's how you destroy that
argument by the way if I'm unable to
sleep with any women it's not the
women's fault right and if a woman is
not able to get a man to commit it's not
the man's fault because we have to be
equal here you want equality there's
equality people are like well as a man
you should do this it's like well it's
like well how do you feel about these
guys that are like really angry at women
we hate them wasn't it your fault you're
not sleeping with them no it's like
they're not attractive okay then isn't
it then likewise your fault that you
can't get a man to commit
um yeah yeah but
and but that's like where sometimes I
feel like
like I feel like a lot of times the way
that men act is in response to the women
because like if we required marriage
before sex like then men would wait like
they would marry us before that but it's
like it's like I feel like a lot of the
way that men like the Trad cons will
like point at the men and be like you
act like this it's like well the women
started it
the problem is it's not it's not um it's
not men or women that are the problem
it's delusional people yeah it's not men
or women's do like like I don't care how
much you want to argue biology you can
negotiate desire you can't argue biology
like like and people that we had this
girl on the show yesterday right like
she just had this belief of how things
should be right you know and I and I sit
down with with guys in our company that
are young they come in guys and girls
and the first three lessons we have a
three-part video series they watch their
first day at work and the three-part
video series is destroying delusion one
destroying delusion 2 and destroying
delusion 3. and I say my goal for you
when you start working here is to
divorce your delusions right divorce
your delusions from you like I want to
point you to like you're going to say
well this works this works this works
but I'm going to show you what actually
works okay that's it and some people go
through that and they are thankful what
are the delusions oh there's like
there's like for example uh there's one
let's talk about sales for a second
there's one delusion that like knocking
on doors and selling doesn't work like
oh people don't buy like that anymore
everybody just buys on dinner that's
just like that Solution that's not true
like we we do Millions a month uh in
Revenue
uh from from cold calling from knocking
on doors it works I mean that's like a
very rudimentary example but it's just a
fact right with men and women it's like
oh my God like I mean you know this like
look I'm 40. what that means is that
like my peer group is also 40. so I see
things from the other side of the fence
now you know what I mean and it's like
all these folks that are like oh you
know
a woman should you know like not get
married blah blah build a career it's
like yeah you've never met like a single
38 year old woman you've not like I I
know them
it's like who do you think a single 38
year old woman's dating pool prospects
are like you're a 38 year old woman is a
30 year old 38 year old single man gonna
date you
it's got to be the older like 10 to 15
years old well so a 38 year old man is
like well I can get a 25 year old woman
and it's like obviously a man's going to
maximize his market for like fertility
and Beauty like that's just biology I'm
not sorry if it's offensive it's just
how it is we know this from a millennia
of human existence it's like okay so
many Millennium human existence so it's
like okay well you're a 38 year old
woman like so the guy you're going after
is he divorced probably like your Market
is just like divorced guys and they
probably have kids because they're
divorced they're probably a little
bitter and they have some child support
payments and so your entire dating pool
is basically reduced like divorced 50
plus
that's a toughest pill to swallow when
you're 38 isn't it yeah so so you know
again when I talk about delusion and
especially like in our company I'm like
I'm just going to show you how things
are I'm going to show you data and
statistics and actual outcomes you can
make your own choices in life I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna make you make a
choice can I have an example of one that
you give to the guy like this is the
delusion this is okay this is the
outcome I'll tell you a really really
simple one one I'll tell you on an adult
one because I think it's going to
connect better with people that are like
in that zone so I tell young guys in our
company you're going to start in our
company you're 22 23 years old you're
gonna be working 60 70 hours a week for
a couple years and your girlfriend has
never seen you work 60 or 70 hours a
week because you've been together since
you're 20 or 21. uh she just expects you
to be home every night to watch movies
and take care of her at some point your
girlfriend's going to come to you and
say pick me or the job
that's what's going to happen wow
because because again when they got into
relationship with that guy that guy was
like in school he had all the Time in
the World to talk to her 17 times a day
to text her back blah blah blah and now
you're gonna be working 60 70 hours a
week and you're going to be in meetings
where you can pick up the phone because
you're in a client meeting you're
picturing a deal blah blah blah blah
right sometimes you have to go in on a
weekend to close the deal that's just
what we do because we're you know
successful men don't work 40 hours a
week like nobody gets Rich working nine
to five and I sell our people like you
come to this company to work your ass
off build a business get rich you're not
going to get rich working nine to five
like you know I mean they're not going
to do flipping burgers you're going to
do it building something significant
okay
so when that your woman comes to you
with that choice if you pick her over
the job you will lose both
if you pick your woman over your job you
will lose both because then she thinks
she can control you well here's how it
actualizes it's scary so here's what
happened they go okay so I cut back my
hours now I'm being out competed by
younger hungry or sharks in the company
who are getting all the sweet deals
because who do I who do we as a company
want to give the best deals to the
people that will be available to pick up
the phone 24 hours a day and close that
deal to make us the most Revenue that's
who the deals go to right so now the
deals are going to somebody else so now
you're losing uh substantial portions of
potential for income
and then the last two times that I've
had this guy in my company different
guys in my company both times they
picked the woman and within a year the
woman left them for another guy wow and
you know who she left them for she left
them for the guy who didn't give up his
job over his woman she left him for an
older wealthier guy who at that age was
just like no I'm gonna focus on myself
and build myself more the woman doesn't
leave her man for a poor lazier man
right like why would you leave your man
for a poor husband out of okay so out of
10 guys that come in with a girlfriend
yeah how many does this happen to and
how many pick the girl
um it's probably well here's what I saw
I'm like look you're gonna have to have
the conversation before you start that
this is how things are going to look and
there's going to be a time to make a
choice so when I married before I
married my wife started dating my wife I
told her up front I was like I work a
lot I'm always on the road I'm busy all
the time this is the ride that that
you're signing up for and I cannot I'm
young enough that I'm gonna have options
for the next 20 25 years I'm not gonna
if you if you come between me and my
ambitions then you become a problem and
I need you to be a solution and that's
just something you have to get on board
with or I'm going to let you know right
now we can just stay you know
buddies because because if you sign up
for this and you become a problem
between me and my career I'm gonna pick
career first
that's the conversation like you're
gonna have to have a conversation with
your girl about that too uh how many it
happens with probably seven out of ten
will pick the job and they're and now
the reason that is pretty good actually
seven out of ten pick the job over the
girl yes I'm surprised it said hi well
what happened is now we have very
concrete examples of before it was just
me saying it but now we have other
people and they're going we got over 100
people in our company so now we have
other guys that are like Hey listen to
Dimitri on this one because I've seen it
happen where this dude picked the girl
and then a year later she left him for a
different guy she leaves so now other
people are backing up what I was saying
so and how how long does it take till
the does the girl usually if he doesn't
pick her leave or no
no no If he if he if he picks the job
she'll say she'll say yeah until he
decides that she's on his way if that if
that's what happens I don't know I mean
I don't want to comment on individual
relationships no usually the usually if
the woman sees her man has like a high
ambition and high potential future a
woman will generally be complicit to
like to like being a part of that plan
and that's what kind of changed my kind
of idea on relationships just observing
it like
and again this is gonna kind of be very
red pilly but like usually a woman is
like really really happy to comply to a
powerful man and I'm not saying could be
coerced this is not coercion because she
could leave at any time it's 80 of women
that leave relationships right but if a
man is ambitious and if a man is on a
mission usually a woman is so thankful
to comply with that because she gets to
be a part of that
which will piss off a lot of people
sorry can you give me another one that's
so interesting the
divorcing delusion from reality yeah
yeah I know what else did we watch my
own videos because it's like it's like a
three-hour lecture yeah this is so
interesting do you can I ask Karel do
you remember any of the delusion stuff
or how we talk about it
for me it was when you told me that the
job is not a job it's a lifestyle that
you Ah that's a huge one yeah
um we talk about this a lot so anybody
that becomes successful in anything
there's no successful people with a job
they have a lifestyle like you you don't
have a job your job is your life is it
not your lifestyle yeah it is like like
so what happens is the most unsuccessful
and we work with over 15 000 multi multi
multi multi-millionaires and ultra high
net worth people it's our client base
over fifteen thousand right so
people that are unsuccessful tend to
have a very separate work and life so
they're like I have my balance they call
it the balance what does that mean so
I'm in at nine I'm I would buy four or
five and then I have my family time and
so job and life for unsuccessful meaning
financially and like and like business
people that are not financially
successful their life and their job are
totally separate
like they have a life and then they have
a job and they and then they say things
like I want balance or my boss can't
call me at home and it's like okay I
won't I don't need to call you at home
right like there's somebody more
ambitious than you that's calling me at
10 p.m saying can you help me right you
know the more successful people become
the more their life and their job become
intertwined and married
that's so true Mr Beast like lives in
his I mean I do too but like he
literally lives in his um office do you
know what I did that's a true story when
I was in Calgary which is where which is
where I was living for six years
building the office
um in Calgary in Canada I had a office
in the 12th floor of a building I ended
up buying the 22nd floor two-story
Penthouse of that building to make it my
home and so I lived on the 22nd story
Penthouse and I took the elevator down
10 floors to go to my office every day
so that way I can just like integrate my
life because sometimes on a Saturday I
need to pop by the office I don't want
to drive 20 minutes I get in the
elevator go down 10 floors into my
office I get my done and so
everything became interested so my wife
knows like for example uh I just went to
Asia I needed to visit my Hong Kong
office so I took my whole family with me
one that I'm going to Thailand for two
weeks I worked from there so my work in
my life said well how do you see your
family and kids I take them on trips I
took my wife to Croatian Hawaii last
year this year I have a business trip
coming up actually a really funny one
you know the guy the meme uh hide your
pain Harold he does The Smiling he's
just like it's a very famous Meme and
I'm doing suits for that guy and he
lives in Hungary so I'm taking my wife
to hungry
I'm I'm meeting Dr Peterson in Bulgaria
uh for a quick meeting I'm taking my
wife to Bulgaria for the weekend so life
and work just become intertwined like
it's just one thing like like for me
life and work don't have a separation
and that's what I tell these guys as
well it's like the more successful you
want to be integrate your life into your
work it's not about working hours it's
about results
it's always about results yeah that
reminds me of how I grew up because it
like we grew up like I feel like I grew
up with a lot of the people that my dad
worked with like it's kind of it kind of
feels like they're like an aunt or
something like the people that literally
worked for my family
um and we like went to India too to like
see because they might they had like a
whole office in India oh yeah it's you
guys right yeah I'm going to India next
week yeah yeah they were yeah but you
know how lucky you are like one of the
things I noticed as well here's another
interesting thing
um this is another thing that if you're
a young person and success is
interesting to you like I'm fascinated
by the topic I'm gonna talk about this
forever it's like I'm just like I look
at it look
I used to visit the CEOs and sell them
suits right and they would have a
receptionist like a secretary and that
secretary was the sharpest damn gal
you'll ever meet like she's so smart and
so quick and just so understanding of
things like I'm like where did you I
know I'd ask these CEOs where did you
find a secretary like that and they're
like oh she wasn't like that when she
started but she gets to spend all day
around the CEO and the people I meet
so so my wife is like she's she's pretty
smart but she's become like really
business savvy like like she'll say
stuff sometimes to remind me of things I
need to remember and I'm just like whoa
that's freaking wise and then she's like
yeah I spent all my day like around you
and around all these business things
that you talk about that's the better
education than in school because it's
real it's so much better than in school
how so you speak about your wife a lot
how did you pick her uh and what advice
do you have to men when looking for a
wife very funny story uh I was I
finished as a top salesman in the book
company uh and then the company asked me
to speak on stage in front of about a
thousand sale other sales people and so
obviously I'm on stage in front of a
thousand sales people so all eyes are on
me so I have like crazy status and I'm
up there and I see this girl and I'm
thinking like oh I'm gonna marry this
girl
that was it and so
um I walked up to her there's a picture
like the moment we met because it was at
a public event that I was speaking at I
walk up to her we talked exchange info
the rest is history now we didn't
actually start dating like exclusive for
like two or three years what she lived
in Estonia I lived in Canada no way yeah
she came to visit me I went to visit her
but I was doing my own thing I was still
whatever right she was in the she was in
the peripheral she was in the picture I
was interested but you know for us to
make a relationship out of it one of us
would had to move countries okay and I'm
like I'm not moving countries for like I
ended up now living in a stone but the
firm I'm not moving countries for like I
have my career here right now in my
business here right now I'm building
here and so uh she basically was like
she wasn't like pressure me but she's
like hey if I come to Canada do you like
expect me to just move in with you
that's what she said I was like yeah
I was like yeah you move in with me and
so she moved to you she moved again so
what made her different than other women
you were seeing
um well I'll say the obvious beauty is
definitely one of them like there was
other beautiful women but to me she
represented that sort of standard that I
Aspire for because she is like my I have
a type like everybody's different I just
have a specific sort of like type she
fed that type that's that's one thing
um
I talk about you know like how are my
mentors and I told the story yesterday
he said that you know pick a woman that
respects her father she really respects
her father that's I find that really
appealing I really like that she speaks
so highly of her dad and how like they
have a good relationship he's a freaking
cool guy too I really get along well
with him
um I like that
um I like that she doesn't have any sort
of even though the social media age
didn't have like a public profile or
anything she never advertised herself or
marketed herself
like there's just none of that you know
what I mean that was very appealing to
me because it was different from like
others she sounds coachable too
she would tell you she's very coachable
she would tell you that would be she
would take a lot of pride in saying I'm
coachable yeah actually she would use
that word yeah and she was willing to
follow you too big time yeah big time
and she sounds really supportive too
yeah big time yeah
but she she said she you know when I
opened my mouth and talked that she
wanted to be on the on the ride like
okay so what advice do you give your
guys when it because you you coach them
to find a wife or something I coach him
I coach him as best I can based on the
success of the people in our company
though so we have tangible success
because we've made many millionaires in
our business now like we have guys and
gals in our company like the girl that
runs our Dubai office Jana has been with
us for seven eight years ago that runs
our Belgian office yours been with us
eight years Eustis in Lithuania eight
years Chanda and Hong Kong 12 years he's
been with us like we have these people
now and our company has been around a
long time that have made a great life
for themselves so we have other examples
we can show them so what we do is we try
the best I can is to show the reality of
the choices they made and the
consequences those choices had you know
and and try to guide them to just like
hey you can do whatever you want but
here's what we've observed tends to work
and here's what doesn't work and you can
do with it what you want
um and if you and if you do the other
thing here's examples of what that other
thing has the consequences of and by the
way you know we had that girl yesterday
she's totally delusional like you're
just telling her like you keep making
the same dumb choices and they keep not
working and you believe they're gonna
it's like that's Insanity right wait so
don't tell me like specifics like what
advice do you tell them because I just
think it would be good because you know
okay we do women that watch the show and
you're and they these are the guys they
want to date so here's one thing I
talked about with Korea yesterday over
breakfast like we were having breakfast
yesterday I said look
um people very much undervalue the cons
the positive consequences of discipline
okay like we really undervalue like I'll
tell you I have some clients that are
very very wealthy and you wouldn't think
that they were super smart or like
cunning but they're really really
wealthy but what you realize is they're
so damn regimented and disciplined
they're like again they're so
predictable like they're just so
reliable and you know and what I've
noticed like as our company has grown
and scaled I'm sure you've seen it in
your company as well you pay a premium
for predictable people like you can have
a very highly talented person that
doesn't show up to work sometimes but at
some point that highly talented person
doesn't show up to work sometimes
becomes so frustrating to work with that
you would rather take a medium Talent
that's super predictable wouldn't you oh
absolutely we had issues with that early
on where it was like yeah but when you
start a company you're generally getting
the shittiest people because you're my
brand you know that's just how it is
right no I got lucky I got a blessing
right yeah no but don't wouldn't you pay
a premium for for reliability yeah yeah
so so that's what I learned like one of
the things I teach are guys it's like
you will get so much further on medium
Talent if you just show up every day and
you do the things that you do the the
those things that require to be
successful in our company needs how many
calls you make to prospects how many
prospects and clients you talk to in a
day how many clients you visit in person
every day if you keep and we have
specific metrics for them like if you do
these numbers you'll be way more
successful than somebody who's very
talented who doesn't do those things
like there's just such a premium that
people receive in life for being
predictable and regimented and
disciplined so going to the gym right
like if you do it every day and if
you're like keeping your you know
whatever dietary whatever restrictions
you place on yourself every day
like the outcome of that in the long
term is preposterous so when it comes to
dating are you telling them to get a
girl that's disciplined because the
original question was yeah like what you
tell no I never said that I mean I can
see that working I I say that your goal
as a man is to maximize your value as
much as you can to create the biggest
pool of potential mates and then pick
from that pool okay and what do you tell
them to pick for uh well support okay
support you know somebody that that
wants to I say this somebody that wants
to join you on your mission we're not
training guys that are going to be you
know uh working nine to five we're
training guys they're gonna be really
busy traveling all the time like try
like one of my top guys right now he
just spent two weeks in Sweden uh
visiting clients then he flew to Norway
because he's training a guy in Norway
he's back home now for two days uh then
he goes to Spain like he and he's got a
young daughter with his wife and I'm
like you know and he knew this when you
joined a company it's like make sure
that your wife is on board because
you're gonna go for a ride
you're gonna go for a ride not everybody
wants to go for that ride some some
women have a or men too but like some
people have a scarcity mentality where
they just want Safety and Security and
what you're providing is Adventure and
growth and that's going to be hard not
everybody wants adventuring growth I
mean everybody kind of like
instinctively wants it but I think they
may be too scared of it too
so
um I say look for somebody that's going
to support you on your mission and that
wants you to win that's actually that
wants you to win you know there's that's
crazy like remember the girls yesterday
on the podcast it's like there are some
girls there that just wanted men to lose
like their whole perspective on life is
like I hope that men lose it's like and
why would it's like I will make a man
successful do you think a man would lose
without you that's a pretty destructive
Viewpoint well and it's like
I hate it when they say that because I'm
like I've grown up a successful man and
it's just like they would be successful
with or without you I mean you can make
their life better and help and get them
to a point where like they're very
thankful and will always CR like you
know but successful men are going to be
successful with or without you because
they're on a mission listen successful
like beautiful women that find a great
husband will be beautiful and find a
great husband with or without you too
that's the thing about self-empowerment
right so I tell our guys this a lot I'm
like I'm not looking for people that are
going to be unsuccessful without us I
want people that would succeed with or
without us but we'll give them the
support and synergies that we can do
better faster and stronger together
that's it I'm not looking for losers
turns winners I'm looking for winners
that are looking for a place to win so
tell me about fashion I know nothing
about fashion I grew up as a tomboy sure
me too Mary and uh very very into sports
um and I'm at the point because of what
I do for work that I'm really trying to
get better at Fashion but it's not
something that really comes natural to
me and I think a lot of guys feel that
way too because they've never most guys
like what kind of what what percent of
guys have really taken a look at their
wardrobe zero percent serious so like
it's the it's the thing that guys are
are not going to tell you but they're
incredibly in Secure about
um and they're a little bit embarrassed
about being insecure about it and when
you think about a guy that goes on a
journey and becomes let's say wealthy
like he's building his life he's going
to buy a nice house first and he's going
to buy a nice car maybe a nice car and
then a nice house clothing is always the
last thing to come up oh so Tom I have a
question yeah what what would you do for
the people that work here like what if I
was gonna up our fashion as a company
what would you suggest for like uniforms
uh I don't know if uniforms is what you
want to go you guys are a creative
operation right like I'm not saying
there's been because I want to unplug us
it's just like we might we and what we
do which is like more of a formal kind
of right right like we might not be
exactly the fit now for you personally
if you're doing wife school and you go
on looking very classy very traditional
that might be a good fit like on brand
right right but I think of King rich is
out here you know I think the guy's
perfectly on brand yeah you know why I
think he's on brand because he's a
college educator former NCAA athlete
athlete and you wouldn't know it until
he opens his mouth and I think that's so
powerful because you look at them you're
like who's the thug right like he knows
it he says it himself he wears chains
and he's got the silver teeth right yeah
then he opens his mouth you're like wow
he's really smart he is really smart and
I'm like that's awesome because young
guys are going to see themselves and I
think a lot of young guys look at me and
they're like suits are so far away and
so distant in their life right and
that's fine that's okay you know not
everybody has to see that but he but he
does that
good Bridge so I'm not training to
change anything so what do you think
about okay average guy coming in I want
to look more professional what do you
tell them well one thing is so here's
the struggle that I had okay so I was I
have a friend uh he is a professional
coach for men who coaches a man how to
meet and attract woman that's what he
does professionally he's been in for 20
years and he's really good at it he's
built a really good business out of it
and I think he's doing God's work
because he's really helping a lot of
guys and I was spending some time with
him and I was not a clothing guy myself
like before I started this business I
knew him from before I started this
business
and he would always talk about dressing
nice
let's say like why do I need to dress
nice you know I go this is actually
really profound I was like you know if I
dress nice women are going to think I'm
trying too hard
he goes no if you don't dress nice women
are going to think that guy doesn't get
it
I was like you know I would love to do
something because my dad is like one of
those Rich guys that doesn't care about
his appearance at all and I was thinking
he won't watch this but I was I was
thinking um that I want to get him like
a nice like watch or something because
my dad I don't know I just feel like
he's like one of those guys that he
would appreciate it but he'd never buy
it for himself do you ever find guys
like that I'm that guy oh yeah my wife
this is a new suit my wife literally
made me throw out like eight suits last
week she made me throw them out because
she's like you've had these for like 10
years they're getting gross because
that's one of the things when you're
self-made by the way when you're
self-made you know you still think you
still think about preserving resources
and things like it's not daddy's money
that I'm spending it's like I know how
hard I work for it yeah so I have a
really hard time spending money on
myself yeah so you you give them the
advice to get suits or like what I would
give guys the advice that you know and I
this is going to sound so cliche but
like dressed to be the person you want
to be okay like just like even just just
putting that out there to the world is
going to attract a different energy
again we're getting metaphysical but
like dress for the person you want to be
um one thing if you're not a guy that
doesn't care about looks get a nice pair
of shoes get a nice outfit and just
notice how differently women treat you
immediately they take you more seriously
uh one thing I've noticed with guys this
is like kind of old mystery stuff if you
will but it's like look if a woman is
going to want to get with you she's
going to want to visit whatever you are
like if you are a video gamey slob and
you look like you've been playing video
games for the last 18 hours in a row
does the woman want to visit that world
is that an interesting and a woman don't
want to visit it right right okay maybe
you're dressed in a suit look a lot of
women want to visit that world and find
out what it's like you know with a guy
in a suit like that's a world you can
visit maybe you know maybe you're really
muscular and that's your thing maybe
that's the archetype you fulfill and you
wear a you know you wear a
short sleeve shirt you can see your
muscles do and women want to visit that
they want to visit Fitness guy like
that's an archetype they want to visit
right whatever that archetype is like
clothing is an archetype um it's a it's
a very quick way to increase your
perceived value and it's not a cheap
thing to increase your perceived value
it's actually a very meaningful thing to
make yourself the best version you can
make yourself why wouldn't you do you
hate yourself
like why wouldn't you be the best
version of yourself yeah
I feel like that's like one way that's
like I feel like a guy that's well
dressed it can like take him up at least
two points easy yeah like from from a
five to a seven yeah so makeup does the
makeup does the same thing for women and
it's like why not like we have this
thing available to us then utilize it
so
you usually get these guys in about 20
yeah 22 23 something how long do they
typically stay with you well that really
depends right so uh the ones that stay
with us for over 18 months uh 53 of our
sales people make over six figures
within 18 months wow
six figures that's an actual statistic
we can back it up like that's in our
company 53 within 18 months Market
leaders in our company market leader
meaning you're about four five years and
about a quarter million dollars a year
but not everybody makes it to that stage
because you have to be very very
consistent right the thing that people
struggle with it's not learning how to
talk to people it's not learning how to
present fabric we're talking about suits
it's not rocket science that we're doing
the thing that people struggle with is
the consistency is you have to get up
and do it every single day and you have
to be on schedule every day and you have
to treat it like it's it's your
lifestyle and a lot of people realize
there are a lot of people probably sixty
percent of people realize hey maybe I
don't want to be working 67 hours a week
maybe I really do value just having a
job at the bank working nine to five and
making my forty thousand a year until I
die and so a lot of people choose
complacency
which is sad to me but they're happy and
you know what let them be happy like
it's fine we're not looking for those
people like we're looking for the we're
looking for the one percent and so
um 50 so half of the people that stay
with you over 18 months they make six
feet within 18 months the ones they
eventually the others get there too
because business tends to compound right
and then
um you help them Get Married Too in a
way you give them dating advice well I
mean I help them I help them become more
successful which ultimately increases
their pool yeah you know like like we've
had lots of guys in our company now
while will our company get married and
have families lots of guys no I don't
sit down with them and say look you need
to get married and have families I'm
like if you want to do your own thing
you can do your own thing but I think
again we talked about it yesterday 85
percent of millionaires are married 85 I
can't believe it's that high no I I
believe like I believe you I'm just
surprised it's that high I'm not
surprised because again here here's
here's because millionaires are they
tend to be methodical methodical
strategic there's one other thing is
that in order to make money you have to
learn how to control chaos because
there's so much chaos like you're
competing against others the market
forces the other competitors everything
is just crazy all the time right and you
come home to Crazy you can't do that
yeah you need control in your personal
life you need that Bedrock you need that
that that pillar that keeps you steady
and going forward so I never sat down
with my guys I'm like look man you got
to get that's not what I said I'm always
like you go be as successful you can
possibly be and over time they just
obviously they kind of just get to the
point where like hey I have so much
craziness it'd be really nice to have
some stability in my personal life
can you tell me what you told me tell
them the story yesterday you said on the
show when you could tell the difference
between like a quarrelsome wife and a
supportive wife based on like the
reaction from the suits yeah well I mean
look so whenever I've worked with
extremely highly famous celebrities I'm
talking like they're so famous that
they're like
you know on TV like very very famous
guys and I've worked with these very
very famous guys their wives respect
them so much and they're always like
when I deliver a suit like that's
amazing you look so good they're just oh
they see their husband the best way they
can see their husbands it's not about
the suit but we've had situations and my
sales people call me about this too
sometimes it's like you deliver to a guy
and you realize like maybe he's spending
a little more than he should because
he's not necessarily at our level but
just what is what it is we're a luxury
brand what happens is then the wife's
like oh it's too like he looks fat blah
blah and she starts almost like
indirectly criticizing the husband
through the suit and look at how this
isn't even blah blah it's like no it's
fine it's just that you don't like your
husband
you know and it's very and it's and it's
at the point where it's so predictable
to us now that we know the outcomes of
what's going to happen that it's like
okay we know what's going on and and
it's funny because now we've seen some
of those guys get divorced we're like
yep
100 like man if your wife insults you
publicly it's like
it's done
yeah I thought sometimes when girls come
on the show and the things they'll say
about their current relationship I'm
just like girl
yeah yeah I mean I mean look respect is
like I tell my wife the same thing I'm
like I I don't Crave Your Love and I I'm
very thankful that you love me I crave
your respect like I want to be a manual
respect you know because I want my kids
to also see me as somebody they can
respect I'm not saying that to be
selfish I'm saying that's just what I
crave and I and I'm not saying that I
deserve it for the fact that I exist I
deserve it through my work I deserve it
through my labor I deserve it for what
happens to the community at large within
our company in the community at large
when I show up and that's what I want
like I want that respect for my work and
if you don't respect my work then then
either my work and my the way that my
life plan is isn't isn't High Enough
or you're just not the person that's
going to be on this journey
and I don't expect to be unemployed and
smoking weed and for you to respect me
that's delusional too right
well it
it's an interesting story
um coming from literally the
multi-million dollar brand that helps
men
um where can people reach out to you if
they want to work for you or you know
have you on their podcast whatever so
just lgbg.com look at look good feel
good it stands that's that's when you
start a company you know what you're
doing you just look good feel good so we
made it and we trademarked LGBT is our
trademark internationally lgfg.com look
good feel good lgbg.com check out our
website we got some cool stuff there we
also got a cool careers page and lots of
videos and
um you know we're not for everyone but
again we're looking for that person
that's like ready to grow up and and to
make themselves better and we're very
very passionate in fact I'm more
passionate I was selling realistic
breakfast this morning like I'm a lot
more passionate now about watching other
people and our company succeed because I
can do it but to see you know I have a
guy that made a uh I won't say who he
made for the first time he made 25 000
in a month it was his first time in his
life making 25 000 months he bought he
bought his mom a vacation and his mom's
friends were like is your son like
dealing drugs like you know because they
can't believe that he's in the suit
business it's 25 000 ours weis's mom you
know to different continent for a
beautiful vacation like it's his mom's a
single mom felt really good about it and
like that brings me so much more joy
than anything else because now I feel
like I'm making an impact and like and I
maybe I'm too young or maybe this is a
pretentious thing to say but like
Legacy and impact feel really damn good
and I really hope more people get to
experience that feeling like it feels
good
well thank you so much for coming on
um guys go
sounds like a great place to work so I'm
like if you I'll kick your ass I'll kick
your ass the clients
I mean look it'll kick your ass because
it'll put you in your place like you'll
learn very because a lot of times too
like if I can say young people come in
and they think of themselves like well I
have a marketing degree so I'm a
professional marketer it's like I'll
tell you something so I was interviewing
a guy I could kill the media company oh
my God oh my God
I'm interviewing a guy and uh he has a
masters degree in international
relations and usually people with
masters degrees I turn them down because
I think they're delusional because I
think if you think that like a master's
degree in international relations or
women's study is going to make you
successful that is so delusional and I
asked him so I put him on the spot I
like to challenge people whenever he's
to see if they can hold their feet
non-delusional I go you have a master's
degree I generally don't hire people
with master's degrees because you're
showing a very academic track mind and
in the real world to succeed it's not
academic it's just doing it's not
thinking it's just doing
he goes yes but I have a degree in
international relations so I'm an expert
in talking to people
oh and I was just like no you know so so
that's a very high level of delusion
most people have a little bit less than
that but here's the thing whatever you
think of yourself the market will tell
you exactly what you are
whatever you think of yourself as a man
women will tell you what you are
whatever you think yourself as a woman
men will tell you what you are and you
have to evaluate the correct metrics if
I made there's a thing that happened
yesterday I thought was interesting
because these girls were like Instagram
I get so many DMS and likes it's like
you're judging yourself on the wrong
criteria
like like it's like that is crazy to
think that you have value because guys
want to sleep with you like every guy
wants to sleep with girls it's just like
they just see you as a Target like what
it's like you know it's like it's like a
sheep oh I'm so valuable because like
lions want to eat me it's like yeah they
do
yeah
um I could go on it's just like
being in the position I'm in it's like
I've gotten crazy DMS but I'm not
delusional I'm like come on you're
telling me if if that guy is dm'ing you
he's trying to get like it's just they
don't get it right so so same thing
happens in our company when people come
on board I'm like look you have an
opinion of yourself on how valuable you
are to society but I'm not going to be
the one that decides that the prospects
and clients you call on they're going to
either spend with you give you revenue
or they're not you're going to learn
very quickly where your true value is
and you're gonna have to make an adjust
and a lot of people that's a wake up
because you know you grew up in North
America especially and all Society tells
you is how special you are how great you
are how successful you are and you get
out to the real world nobody cares about
your problems like prospects aren't like
I don't give like I mean it's like I
don't do not bring any problems I don't
care I don't know you and I don't care
the world it doesn't owe you understand
even the girl in the show she kept
talking about how I had this horrible
background and I can sympathize I I
certainly grew up well you know I didn't
really have any crazy stories happen to
me but it's like at the end of the day
nobody knows that when you're walking
down the street so no one cares
she's gonna have a hard time and she's
had a hard time now imagine her at 60.
this is sad it's really sad and it's
like a lot of times people think I'm
like being mean but I'm not even trying
to be mean it's just like what do you
think's on the other side of this like
and a lot of times these girls come in
and they want to live and I grew up with
the one like in a one percent family
right I would say we grow up more upper
middle class you know lifestyle wise but
it's like
these men would never talk to you my
brothers are making the kind of money
you you would never get in the door they
actually literally see you as a clown
yeah that's just the clown right and I'm
like just based on like even just the
way that you take criticism like they
would never talk to you in a million
years they ask you a question so would
you think it would be a good or a bad
thing for women if you if you're a woman
you go up in front of a panel of
successful guys and they tell you
unfiltered truth exactly what they think
about you do you think that would be
beneficial for some of them oh my God
that'd be so beneficial like unfiltered
like here's the damn truth I would 100
put that up like I would totally I just
don't know successful guys don't
typically want to do I don't give I
don't give a crap guys I'll tell you
right now I'm unfiltered we're not a
corporate type of company we're a sales
organizational entrepreneurial just
plugging it right now yeah um that's why
I'm comfortable going on this and
telling the truth that I wait that I see
it because I'm not afraid of losing like
I'll fail and it's fine could you put
together a panel like that yeah
absolutely we could do it I got I got
some dudes in my company that are like
really attractive and really successful
very Rich really yeah I just went uh
watch shopping with one of my guys he
was buying a 50 000 watch wow he's a
Salesman in our company so we and he's
married got kids we got guys like that
in our company right but here the reason
I asked if that would be beneficial for
the women if you go into sales uh you're
gonna very quickly hear that from your
clients because they don't know you they
don't owe you anything and they'll tell
you exactly how worthwhile or worthless
you are because we could even do that
they go on like short dates with them oh
they're married I don't think oh okay
okay no I was thinking like if they were
single just like then after they can
give feedback what we'd have to do is
actually get them on a panel just ask
them very specific questions about their
beliefs and then give them direct
feedback on those beliefs you know
combination of how they present
themselves right and what their beliefs
are like the lady yesterday the 39 year
old she's a nice looking 39 year old
lady but and she might be like a seven
but like when you talk to her and ask
her very specific question about her
belief she's a one like just the one
like and that's what that's it's like
sometimes it's so sad because it's like
these girls will like some of them in my
eyes you have a lottery ticket yeah like
they're they're beautiful and I'm just
like you're getting the like girls would
be so excited like maybe not hurt but
I've had different examples of that
where I'm like girls would be so happy
to be born looking like you and then
they'll get a tattoo sleeve they'll be
super overweight they'll it is just like
you were given the lottery ticket in
life and you're just pissing it away why
well and you know and for guys when I
tell this to the young guys in our
company talk about some of the things we
teach I say look as a guy I don't care
what you look like you're always a five
but you can become a nine but you're
always a five you're always a five like
you just have to treat life like that
like I didn't go into uh into my life
thinking that I was overtly more
attractive to women I just assume that
women don't know I exist unless I'm
doing something meaningful and that's
what I tell guys I'm like just assume
that nobody knows you exist until you're
doing something meaningful and then
those that that believe it they do it
those that don't believe it once they
start doing something meaningful they're
like wow I'm getting so much more
attention from we in our company
actually Jason's our president I told
you Jason he's the president of our
company Jason value is amazing I think
his mom had like four or five kids with
four or five different guys that's the
home he grew up in wow just like totally
dysfunctional but he becomes he's the
president of our company uh he's been in
the business a long time he's an
absolute stud like he's flying to LA
right now to meet with like all these
celebrities to measure them for our
company he represents us to the
celebrity brands uh to the celebrity
people and um
he has this thing he says he calls it
the six figure glow so we have a guy
named Andrew he runs our Toronto office
one of our top sales guys Andrew hello
and uh Andrew uh was making like 40 000
a year and and a Jason went out to
recruit him to bring him to her company
and Andrew's like well you know blah
blah blah Jason's like look Andrew I'm
just gonna give you one thing and if
this comes true then you can trust me if
it doesn't come true you can go do
whatever you want but he was selling
copiers and he hated it sounds familiar
he hated selling coffee oh that's the
worst job in the world so but we brought
him into sell suits it's the same this
is our product is fun and different yeah
like we're not like how are
water is printing needs per month it's
like we don't ask you we're like hey man
yeah we're like hey man how'd you like
to buy a ten thousand dollar suit and
just show off everybody at your
anniversary so go show me what you got
it's just a different kind of sale yeah
Okay cool so Jason's like Andrew I'm
gonna give you a challenge I'm gonna
stay with me 18 months get to six
figures and then come and then tell me
if the six figure glow is true so what's
the six figure glow so Jason has this
Theory and this is how he coaches young
men this is his style he goes once you
start making six figures women see you
you're like they don't know you but
you'll be walking on the street and it's
like they have truth goggles on women
can smell status can't they and they
have these goggles on all the time and
then you they just see you're glowing
you're one of the six figure blowers and
then and then like that glow becomes
brighter and brighter and brighter so
Andrew I remember this uh he made like
nineteen thousand dollars commission one
month that month put him over a hundred
thousand for the year
got a girlfriend beautiful girlfriend a
great girl
she's actually super super cool and like
he always speaks so highly of her
um and he called me and he's just like
dude does Andrew that's how he talks
dude uh
so yeah like
man like the six figure glow it's
totally true so it was just like this
realization that like he had the
six-figure glow so I tell guys you know
you're a five you're a five but you have
to build yourself women are a little bit
different I think from a lot of women
which is really crazy to me they end up
destroying their value more than they
don't have to do that much in order to
have value when they're young they just
have to remain pretty like grounded but
then they just destroy it and I don't
know why
I mean I think it's a lot of lack of
like fathers in the home to be honest I
mean I don't know if you notice like all
the girls with a more crazy mindset did
like that they all basically didn't have
dads yeah and it's it's sad because a
lot of those girls go on to repeat the
same mistakes and end up like also being
a single mother well that's my mentor he
said find a girl that respects her
father I mean I didn't get it at the
time but that was like
that probably saved me a lot of
Heartache yeah yeah it's
and and I also feel like it's important
for guys to have a girl that like
listens to them because you just don't
want to date a girl that's always
arguing with you about everything that's
a headache that's such a headache you
know my brother's girlfriend
um he makes six figures my brother is so
smart he's an engineer works for
government company on top of that
um he reads more than anyone I know like
on the planet and he just wrote a book
and I bet you he makes a ton of money
because I don't know who else I don't
know anyone else that reads as much as
my brother right and his girlfriend
fiance now I was like this is how she
got the ring she went to culinary school
she's an engineer she went to culinary
school after work to cook for my brother
and it's like what percent of girls are
willing to do that ask him if she still
asks him what to cook for dinner because
that's one thing it's your life when
you're growing your life becomes so
chaotic my wife doesn't ask because I'm
like I don't want to tell you what to
cook for dinner like I just that's I
don't want any micro decision it's not
even I don't want arguments I don't want
to make micro decisions they're
inconsequential decisions to me and so
sometimes I see like I've seen my
friends get married not my friends
people I used to love them anymore but
like and they would be like so involved
in the micro decisions of their wedding
I'm like your marriage going to fall
apart why because your fiance your wife
whatever is making you go through the
tenuous like exercise
of like
putting time and energy into the micro
decisions of the wedding cards and I
also that's not a woman that's behind
you and I also feel like
like all the stuff she does all this are
you kidding me we talked about this
yesterday yeah because it's just like a
headache to him you know um that exists
that actually happens still that's crazy
no yeah crazy that's why that's why when
you hear the stuff on the show and the
girl's like oh I give so many chances
all it like to me that's you saying I'm
always gonna keep score you because you
don't think he's given you chances what
are you God so they don't think they're
replaceable which is which is a bad
thing to say but like we're all
Replacements no I'm replaceable like
we're all replacing yeah and that's and
that's the thing like it's like these
girls will well it's like there's never
any humility like what did I do you know
um and that's why I hate it when girls
are like well I gave him so many chances
I'm like that's just that's just either
you choose bums that's either that's
either translation for you choose bums
or you
um don't date Matt like you choose men
that don't really like you you know it
was interesting yesterday the girls were
like oh you know all these millionaires
that I meet they're all cheaters and I
uh and you ask so many milliliters you
know they're like two which they
probably don't know any but I know I was
that's how I say I like cap so I looked
at the statistics and about two
one-third of million are statistically
speaking based on the best data from
February 2023 this year one third of
millionaires cheat one out of three
Which is higher than the non-million the
one I saw was 50 uh 50 within a relate
the chances of somebody cheating within
a relationship is 50 oh okay it's
marriage just one out of three yeah
because because women's propensity to
cheat goes down as their wealth goes up
in a marriage which means the husband's
making more money the woman's less
likely to cheat why because the
hyperbole becomes harder because yeah
whereas men's propensity goes up because
opportunities become higher someone you
know so that makes sense
and I'm like okay so two out of three
millimeters wouldn't cheat why aren't
they picking you that's the real
question right it's like why aren't they
picking you because the other guys are
why are the other guys picking you
that's interesting
yeah and that's I'm just a big believer
in accountability I feel like everything
in life's your own fault 100 and I just
don't I just cannot stand what everyone
it's everyone else's fault I'd say it's
not your fault it's your responsibility
remember that difference right like like
if you're 15 and your you know dad
leaves the family that's not your fault
like you can't be responsible for that
action as a child but the responsibility
of dealing with the following after that
I mean that girl was 39 she's like I'm
on a journey I'm like your Journey's
over man you're 39 years old and you
haven't like realized that you're doing
stupid things with your life you know
and it's 30 enough that's why when
they're like oh I'm Gonna Be A
Millionaire and I'm just like nope I
grew up around millionaires like and I'm
like I'm telling you talking to you
you're not no you don't want you don't
have the energy like you can just tell
like when I talk to you I can just tell
you're a high energy person like she
knows the glow see I told you guys women
know the globe no but it's not even like
I bet you had that energy when you were
younger too it's like
I yeah probably yeah I wouldn't have
recognized the performance you just you
just seem like the type of guy that can
just like work work work work work and
you just seem passionate but most of the
successful people you know I think all
the successful people you know you're
like you're like that you're working all
but this is a weekend this is Easter and
you're working during and you're working
until midnight tonight yeah well to me
no I'm not I don't have a show tonight
yeah yeah but to me it's just fun like I
do something I love like it's funny
because a lot of times I get accused of
the space of like doing it for money and
I'm like it's funny because I'm just not
motivated by money it's actually so
funny you say that so I came back to my
office and one of the guys in my office
was like what's Pro like in real life
I'm like because people want to know if
you're playing a character and this is
something I get a lot working with
people that are sort of known and your
starters get a little bit known yeah let
me tell you something Jordan Peterson
exactly the same one person who's on
camera there is absolutely no character
that he's playing he is exactly what you
see his mannerisms like he's like you
know like the he'll do that like exactly
the same
exactly the same like like off camera
you're exactly the same there's no
there's no fakeness here like I'm not
playing a character either like
successful people aren't playing
characters they just they they live
their life to the best of their ability
and accountability that's it yeah and
just for me I just enjoy making cool I
just like projects like I'm doing this
documentary on the court system here and
I talk about it all the time no it's
it's really sad it is sad it's so like I
honestly I what did I tear up I tear up
like every interview I do it for I need
to introduce you to my friend he's a
men's right Advocate full-time lawyer
full-time men's rights Advocate I would
love to I would love to have you he will
his story will absolutely crush your
soul what he had to go through uh he
he's got he'll tell you he's got kids
that he hasn't seen in like 10 15 years
he hasn't seen him since they're four
five years old and he's not he doesn't
know his own kids and he he left his job
as a corporate lawyer to become a
full-time men's rights advocate and his
story is insane and he he's helped me
with some projects in Australia because
we became viral in Australia over a
story that uh kind of put us into
international news as a tailoring
company and he called me up he's like
man I want to talk to you because I love
what you're doing blah blah blah and I
got to know the guy he was the one that
actually introduced me to some people I
ended up working with later like some
famous people but ah I would just sit
and just feel like this heaviness in my
chest over what his ex-wife did to him
he got exonerated fully for everything
but obviously there were accusations
that were strategically placed in order
to undermine his divorce settlement and
it was so
evil
so so duplicitous I couldn't believe
that that I just felt like anyways you
should talk to him all right no I would
love to help it's
it made me realize you know I never had
sympathy for homeless people I never
never because in my head
I knew Akai of a couple relatives that
ended up homeless yeah and I can 100 say
that they are homeless because of their
poor Life Choices of course and my um
one of them is an aunt of mine and the
reason that she's homeless is because
she's robbed every single family member
that let's like she stayed with us she
robbed it's just like I mean it's never
big stuff but it's just like you don't
want to thief in your house so now she
ends up on the street and so when she's
on the street I don't feel bad and she's
on her journey
[Laughter]
boy we've been hearing that for twice by
the way I publicly I agree with you yeah
in this society today but but until I
started talking to a guy on my show or
um for this documentary that is homeless
and I found out he he was divorced right
and she took all of the house that he
still had to pay for because it was all
in his name he had to pay over 1500 a
month because he had good money he then
lost his job because he was so stressed
out and he was working yeah but the
payments remains he couldn't keep up of
course correct and then on top of that
he had abuse allegations and he hasn't
seen it from other jobs he hasn't seen
him kids in over a year how could he not
be homeless I can't even think of how
like and then that's where men will get
zeroed out and commit suicide and I was
like
if if I was in that position do you
understand now why I tell the young guys
in our company that are single to sleep
with as many women as they possibly can
yeah because they because now they can
recognize those signs see look that
guy's problem wasn't that he's the bad
guy that guy's problem was that he was
bad with women because a man that's good
with women wouldn't have chosen that
woman because he would have seen some of
the signs yeah 100 he was saying that he
she was from like a Muslim background
like a more traditional background again
but he's he a good judge of that clearly
not the results matter like I I feel bad
for the guy I mean obviously you got
taken advantage of by some form of
psychopath or narcissist that happens
all the time right but like if you are
not good at recognizing those signs like
when you were in sales you probably had
to learn to recognize when somebody was
not the decision maker but they were
pretending to be yeah and that's very
frustrating or somebody that told you
they had the budget but clearly they
couldn't afford you but they had a lot
of time for somebody that should have a
budget and then you realize they don't
have the budget that's what you realize
when the meetings are too long with them
they're never gonna buy of course right
so so you learn so so yeah right voila
you recognize the pattern right now
imagine for a lot of guys that don't
have that sort of access to women they
don't know what they're dealing with
they're in that meeting for a year
thinking the prospect is going to buy
they're not gonna buy
um so they are partially responsible for
the fact that they weren't educated to
be self-serving enough because if they
were they would have gone through a few
women and then said hey you know what
there's something that's different here
and I don't like it so he made he made
some concessions early in that
relationship he acquiesced a little bit
too much and it led to that and that's
exactly what happened so guys if you're
listening to this
um
before I started uh well so while I
started like in sales one of the things
I also did at that time and this was now
early 2000s nobody was doing this yet
it's completely considered uncouth now
whatever it is but like back then it was
a new thing is I would approach girls on
the street and ask for their numbers
people thought it was insane now you
know you see that and it's probably
looked down upon in some circles some
people are like hey like why did I do it
because like I wanted to learn how to be
able to multiply my options I saw that
as a positive thing I got rejected a
tongue like I you know what there
was a cute girl that lived in my
building in Vancouver I was living in
Vancouver at the time 19th floor
and I and I just saw that she would have
like these other cute girls come over to
her house she was a neighbor and I
didn't know who she was I just went
knocked on her dorm okay I wanted to
introduce myself I live next door I
thought you guys were having some
parties you know I I kind of want to be
a part of that you know like like how
are you like I look a total doofus kind
of thing she's just like what you're
just knocking on doors meeting girls
like pretty much you know but but you
know what but like again the average
billionaire goes broke 3.5 times right
so what are we not afraid of we're not
afraid of failure we're not afraid of
being resilient getting back up and
trying again and I tell guys you don't
need money to meet girls get good with
women because it'll be a skill for your
in life when you have to not have to
when you choose to choose a wife if
that's the direction that you go right
you want to be educated before you make
that choice right well and you don't
know what's on the other side of that
door it could be your wife I mean it
wasn't but you know no just listen like
the the the the core of it is the same
thing as well man it's like if you're a
woman you know um and you're a bad judge
of character you're gonna have a tough
life that's it's harder for women to
date than men I really believe that like
I know some people say this and it's
like no because men and if they're smart
they're they're looking at they're
they're maximizing their value and
they're looking at a woman's past now
women will try to hide their past but
the past is a lot easier to predict than
the future right it's like I can look
like one of our guys right now we're
just laughing about he got he's dating
this girl and we're all looking like oh
no
oh no he doesn't see it yeah yeah but
but it's like but here's the thing we
can see it because we understand what it
says about the past but for a woman to
look at a man's future requires to be a
good judge of character that's hard
especially if you don't have good Role
Models good male role models in your
life to be that sort of uh ideal right
to pursue you know
and a lot of times like we want the
roller coaster but the guys that like
you should be with are more methodical
as you were saying well you have to you
know if you realize that too late and
you're 32 by the time you realize it
you're gonna have a tough life yeah like
you should really you should definitely
get your heart crushed both as a man and
or as a woman you should go through
rejection and heartbreak because that's
part of The Human Experience like you're
not if you're living to mitigate against
heartbreak you're gonna have a very bad
life also so it's not about reducing
that's the other thing we talk about is
you can't go into stuff scared because
like won't work out yeah because
like that's like oh he might leave you
high and dry if you give it like if you
give up your career you have kids or
whatever it's okay he might it's like
fail fail but then don't make the same
mistake twice like you should fail you
should go out and find different ways
like it's not that you're succeeding too
little it's that you're failing too
little yeah and then of course the girl
yesterday she fails a lot but then she
keeps keeps doing the same thing it's
like fail and then take corrective
action iterate to Perfection yeah yeah
well we we do have another interview you
coming up so I have to get this thank
you but um you are so interesting the
the fans love you so we're definitely
going to have you back
um thank you so much for coming out
hello fans I love you tell them tell
them again where to find you lgemg.com
guys look good feel good lgfg.com uh
we're a custom clothing suit high-end
suit company but what we're looking for
are those young men and women that are
looking to build a career
internationally we have a guy that
started with us in Europe he just moved
to Hong Kong now what works out of our
Hong Kong office we got a girl at
Starbucks in Australia had a dream of
working in Dubai you know runs our Dubai
office uh we're International we're
growing
um and we like kicking ass and if you
like that
lw.com sounds like such a cool place to
work
um guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell make sure stay tuned
because he's going to do a wife School
episode with me where we show that yeah
we're gonna show the the suit the 19th
yeah and we're gonna go through the
Fashions that'll be good like the video
on your way out and we'll talk to you
next time